had to do an internship came to
Washington interned here in Washington
went home graduated and then came back
to work for the Reagan campaign and I've
actually been here in this town
since 1980 and very fortunate to be
working with a number of people in this
town and both in the executive branch
and in the legislative branch and Joann
Jenkins is the CEO of AARP and she is
the author of this book disrupt aging a
bold new path to living your best life
at every age and 50 is the new 50 as she
says thanks for being on book TV thank
you it's my pleasure and book TV is live
at the 16th annual National Book
Festival here at the Convention Center
if you're in the area come on down and
see us we're passing out our annual book
TV bags so you can pick this up and our
day is just beginning we've got hours of
live coverage coming up you'll have a
chance to talk with authors Bob Woodward
representative John Lewis and Ken Burns
throughout the day today and you'll hear
from many other authors including Jon
Meacham his most recent book is a
biography on a president 8 George HW
Bush coming up next and by the way you
can find the full schedule of book TV
org coming up next in the history and
biography room we're going to go back up
there it's Candace Maillard her most
recent book is about Winston Churchill
and it's called hero of the Empire this
will be beginning soon this is book TVs
live coverage on c-span 2
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
say again I'm not gonna read you the
rules and regulations because I suspect
you've heard them three times already
and in any case I've forgotten them all
my name is Jonathan Yardley and I am
here ostensibly from the Washington Post
but I left it a long time ago about 18
years ago my wife and I were living on
Capitol Hill with my stepdaughter who
was working at the con at the National
Geographic and one day Hollis said to
her I bring a friend home from the
office for dinner and he said sure I'm
afraid that that's a technical problem
that someone else is going to have to
cope with if I shout does that help our
my stepdaughter was working at the
National Geographic and one day asked if
she could bring a friend home for dinner
and we said sure so the next day at
dinner time this lovely young woman
shows up with our my stepdaughter doll
and my wife and I were immediately in
chatted with her and she is still lovely
and young and enchanted but now she's
one of the most respected most
accomplished and most successful writers
of serious nonfiction in the United
States
Janice is very good to see you again
it's very good to see you
and could I just say just very briefly
what an incredible honor it is to sit
here with Jonathan Yardley who all of
you know is such an a huge figure in the
world of journalism and in the world of
books and and if you buy some crazy
chance you don't know his work I I urge
you to go out and find it he's really
absolutely brilliant so it's very
humbling to me I should be interviewing
him because he's a much more interesting
figure than I am so anyway I just wanted
to flattery will get you everywhere okay
we will get over to the Winston
Churchill and hero of the Empire soon
enough I have a couple of questions
about how you got to this point in your
life you were at national do for what
four five years six years six years
national deal has a reputation for being
a very tightly if not severely ended
publication you were an editor and you
were a writer what what influence did
your years there have on your own
evolution as a writer well I always say
that my real education actually happened
at at National Geographic I learned so
much about storytelling about the fact
that the world is full of fascinating
people fascinating events and stories
but most of all I learned about research
and I learned that you need to dig
deeply you need to take the time to
understand it and you need to find the
people who really know the subject that
you're going to look into you know at
National Geographic you could be working
on something about meerkats one day and
it's something about a river another day
so it really fluctuated and so but the
one consistent thing throughout is that
there's always somebody who knows the
subject and knows it really really well
and has spent most of his or her life
studying it and you need to find that
person and make him your friend
[Music]
we're not how did it come to you that
you should try to write what became the
river of doubt being a young you were
not a trained historian the subject
involved traveling to a dangerous place
dealings with languages other than your
own tell us about the challenges and
apprehensions that confronted - as you
started out so I first heard the story I
was having lunch with a friend of mine
James Chase who wrote the book 1912 did
you know and I'm really an extraordinary
man and this is the election you know
the bull moose election where Roosevelt
tried to regain the presidency and lost
and he said have you heard about this
trip that Roosevelt took in the Amazon
after that election and and I had read
about Theodore Roosevelt I was
interested in him but because it's after
his act of political career was sort of
glossed over and I started researching
it actually and went back to National
Geographic they have a great library
there and and then went to the Library
of Congress and I was stunned because
you know there's murder drowning you
know they left the murderer and the
rainforest Roosevelt nearly took his own
life I would set in the Amazon the
richest ecosystem on earth something I
would love to write about and so I was
just hooked right away but it is
daunting to take on Theodore Roosevelt
to take on the Amazon to take on a book
exactly but but I was really excited
about it because I knew that to write or
this is just a gift it had so much to
work with and I
thanks to my years at National
Geographic I knew how to do research
that was the only thing that I was
confident about but you went to the
Amazon right I did I did I went to this
River which is still incredibly remote I
did some research on Rio
and and then I went to this little town
and Northwestern Brazil called Porto
Velho I rented a plane I hired a pilot
and I flew four hours over unbroken
rainforest horizon to horizon and this
raises the question how do I get the
money to do that well I had an advance
yeah so I yeah
from Doubleday so I had gotten an agent
and in fact James chase sent my proposal
to his agent very generous man
unfortunately he passed away right
before the book came out which was
really difficult for me but anyway so
Doubleday gave me this great advance you
get it kind of in three parts one part
you know when you sell it one part when
you turn in the manuscript and one when
it comes out so I had that money and I
that's how I used it well I would have
thought you would have flown the plane
yourself nope well I say that because in
river of doubt as in your other two
books you're incredibly generous in your
acknowledgments you seem to deal with a
great many people and travel to a great
many places you've seen and endlessly
curious and afraid afraid of nothing
well that's not true I'm actually I have
a lot of fears but I I think my fears
are sort of shadowed by my interest did
you go down into him did you go down a
mine in South Africa I went to where the
mine was it's no the coal Yuri is is
closed now but but there's the hole
where where it was absolutely yeah um so
far you've written about Teddy Roosevelt
James Garfield and Winston Churchill
what if any common elements drew you to
their stories so what interests me and
we were talking about this earlier I
love to read biographies but as a writer
I like to tell a tighter story a more
sort of personal story where I can spend
five years really focusing and digging
in deep and I I'm looking for a story
that I hope is illuminating
about the person and about the time in
which they live and specifically what
interests me I think that often when we
look at history we're kind of drawn to
the big public moments of of triumph or
of infamy but what interests me are the
more private moments of struggle when
someone is sick like James Garfield or
terrified like Theodore Roosevelt or
desperate like Winston Churchill and and
and searching for a foothold and
uncertain and I think it's in those
moments and it's true for for all of us
it's it's something that we all share
that we share with these sort of great
historical figures isn't that that's
when your your true nature is revealed
and quite specifically what drew you to
Winston Churchill and his role in the
Boer War
so I had heard this story 25 years ago
my husband was a journalist for the New
York Times for years and he actually
began his career in South Africa
covering the ANC African National
Congress in the early 80s and when I met
him 25 years ago he mentioned to me he
said did you know that Winston Churchill
was a prisoner of war in South Africa
and that he escaped and I thought you
are kidding me
how do I not know this and so it just
stayed with me all of these years and
after I turned in the manuscript for my
second book we went to lunch and he said
do you have any ideas for your next book
and I said you know I would love to
write about Winston Churchill on the
Boer War and he said yes and and so it
went from there I wondered reading your
wonderful book with its story of
Britain's nearly disastrous war in a
place that's scarcely understood at all
I wondered if the Vietnam War was
somewhere in the back of your head when
you were writing that to be honest
nothing was really in the back of my
head and I can see the can see it but to
be honest so you know I as you know I
have three kids I live in Kansas City I
have just this very normal day-to-day
life with laundry and dinner plans and
stuff but I have an office outside of my
home and when I go into my office and I
close the door it's like a time machine
you know I literally feel like I'm going
back in time and I just immerse myself
and the the documents that I've gathered
and the and the pictures and maps and
things like that and I'm really only
thinking about about this moment in
history speaking of time you seem to be
very strongly drawn to the late 19th and
early 20th centuries I do
III think that's fair
I I didn't set out that way I didn't
think I this is what I want to write
about and I never do but I do find it
very evocative you know I do feel like I
can really you know that time here you
can see it you can smell it you can
taste it I mean it's and but especially
what interests me in it is that there's
so much primary source material you know
it's just this enormous wealth of
letters and diaries and newspaper
articles and especially for the kind of
writing that I do with a narrative
nonfiction you have to have that and you
have to have not like a lot or not even
a huge amount but you have to be
drowning in it and there there are
certainly times when I'm working on a
book and the research takes me most of
the time that I'm working on a book and
I feel like good god I will never get
through all of this I've done projects
much less ambitious than yours but there
when you have that wealth of research
material of course there is the problem
of choosing what to use that's right
that's right but I would be interested
to see if you agree but I I think that
and most of it I don't actually you have
to whittle it down and you have to be
tough about it but I feel like all of it
kind of
in forms you know me and I hope the
reader in the book and you because
because you have to truly understand it
before you can begin writing about it so
whether or not it actually makes it into
the book it does in a sense that I
understand this event much better
because of it one thing about the late
19th and early 20th centuries Churchill
remarks on him and his memoir my early
years is that it's really a lost world
is that it's the period when the world
began to change in incredibly dramatic
ways even more than it's changing now
because you literally went from the
horse and buggy to the cart of airplane
in that period right and that's another
thing actually that interests me about
because the world was changing so
quickly in every conceivable way but
also our knowledge of the world you know
this is sort of the Gilded Age of
Exploration you know and and so that too
is absolutely fascinating and and
Churchill was right in the middle of
that he's he's right on the cusp of of
this incredible change and and it's
fascinating to see it through his eyes a
couple of things that are connected you
right as Churchill escaped the Boer
prisoner of war Kaplan faced dangerous
challenges quote it would be a grand an
adventure an exploit of the most
dramatic kind the notion of British
ideas of Wars as war as a romance is a
strong undercurrent in your book yet
William Manchester in his introduction
to Churchill's memoir my early years
says that his experiences in India and
then in South Africa led him to see
quote the glorification of war or the
fraud it was do you agree with that
judgment yeah I do it's you know at that
time the British Empire was huge you
know ruled 450 million people quarter of
the population and they were spread all
over the world and so they were spread
very thin you know they're constantly
putting down putting down revolts but to
them you know these little colonial wars
that they would fight it was all about
gallantry
and being dashing and they hated losing
their red coats you know they thought
the khakis make them look like bus
drivers and they were still even you
know for the Boer War when it began they
were still fighting in these perfect
precise lines so the Boer War really was
a prelude to World War one it absolutely
was it was the beginning of modern
warfare and I think you know not that
many Americans especially know much
about the Boer War but it was some of
the first guerrilla fighting it was the
first concentration camps the modern
modernisation of weapons and all of
those things to the the British Army
going in was completely different from
the British Army coming out in it and it
prepared them from World War one you
write really splendid ly about the Boers
people whom most of us know about whom
we know very little is the Boer presence
in South Africa still very strong well
they obviously the prelude to the
Afrikaners and and unfortunately things
are changing a lot you know the the
Boers were interesting people they were
they were very independent they're very
religious and they were unabashedly
racist and you know that's sort of what
I'm you may have heard of the Great Trek
with in 1835 they moved from the Cape
hundreds of miles into the interior and
that was set up primarily by the fact
that two years earlier the British
Empire had abolished slavery and so even
though the the British Empire promised
people in Africa native Africans and the
Indian population that was living there
that as soon as they won the war things
would change and be better for them as
we all know that took much longer than
anyone would have hoped and so of course
there is still an Afrikaner presence but
you know obviously Nelson Mandela was a
huge breaking point for that and and
things have changed quite a bit tell us
a little bit about Churchill why he did
change his
the experience in South Africa did
change him but I kept thinking as I was
reading your book that are perfectly apt
title for it would have been naked
ambition yeah absolutely he was just a
bundle of burning ambition that was that
the one description of him that's
absolutely true throughout his life that
is traceable to his feelings about his
father some of it I think it was I don't
know do the ambition and and well to do
was they weren't rich in the British
but prominent naked ambition is not that
really all that common and in that
particular class it's looked down a book
down upon and I've always thought that
that was an American and him his mother
the beautiful socialite Jennie Jerome
was American and and he in fact he told
his mother this is a pushing age and we
must push with the best and so he was
very connected she had all these
powerful men who adored her and so he
was always having her you know helped me
out here have this person get me an
assignment cuz he was always throwing
himself into Wars because he thought
that's the best way for me to win Fame
and propel myself to political power and
he called it the glittering gateway to
distinction right you quote at the end
of a famous remark by his first love
Pamela Plowden Bowden who said when you
first meet Winston you see all the
things that are wrong with him and once
you get to know him you see all the
things that are right with him what was
wrong what was right as you came to know
him well so what was wrong he was
obviously not only ambitious but
incredibly incredibly arrogant and that
is probably two dozen
there and throughout his life it was
absolutely all about about him in fact I
I found it entertaining because again
and again and again in in letters and
journals and different newspaper
articles people would say you know that
that Winston Churchill I cannot stand
the kid he's going to be Prime Minister
one day but he drives me crazy
they're using story that she tells us
while he was in prison in South Africa
he ordered her tweed suit yeah anyway
went to South Africa with what cases of
champagne and you know ten-year-old
whiskey right so he you know he's
willing to risk his life but he doesn't
even want to be uncivilized while he's
at it
but but but but what was interesting
about him to me at this point in his
life is if you look at pictures of him
you almost don't recognize him so
obviously we think of Winston Churchill
we think of the older ones in Churchill
during war and he's overweight and he's
older and he's got his cigar and his
whiskey and this one he's young and he
has red hair and he's sort of energetic
and he's the one throwing himself into
war but inside inside he was already the
Winston Churchill we know and it's it's
fascinating to read the letters that he
wrote at that time and there was one in
particular that he wrote to Pamela
Plowden so he he ran for Parliament
before the Boer War and he lost but
during the election and he's loving it
he's loving all of these opportunities
to be on a stage and and he writes to
her he says you know I don't know what's
going to happen with the election I
don't know what the outcome will be but
with every speech I give I feel my
growing powers something you don't go
into in the book cause it really occurs
after the period that you cover what
happened between him and Pamela so this
is a great story actually because he was
in love with her she was this beautiful
young woman he had met her actually in
India when he was there fighting in
British India and and she was sort of
the toast of London when she went back
and so she had many admirers but he was
in love with her and he wanted to marry
her but her father wouldn't let her
marry him
because he didn't think that Churchill
would amount to anything finally Candice
before we turn this over to questions
from the floor
could you say a few words about popular
history in his favorable notice of your
Bureau of the empire that reviewer for
The Wall Street Journal last week
describes you as quote a smooth writing
popular historian I guess that was a
compliment but the phrase popular
history has always seemed to me to be
slightly pejorative and condescending
even though much of the best history now
being written these days is being done
by non academics max Hastings
Anthony Beevor David McCullough yourself
I'm sure you you're pleased to be put in
such company but do you ever feel
defensive about being popular i I don't
you know I to be honest I feel so
incredibly fortunate to be able to do
what I do every day I go to work I think
we can't believe that this is my job you
know my job is to read most of the time
and to dig into these fascinating at
least to me fascinating stories and you
know I know a lot of historians I read a
lot of academic histories and I respect
them it's just not what I do and and I
hope that in that it's actually a
collaborative saying you know I hope
that there are people who a lot of
people I've met who say you know I I
thought I hated history I was never
interested in history and then I read
something by David McCullough or Anton
beaver and I was I was hooked and a lot
of times they say and it made me want to
know more and so then I started to read
more deeply and I and I so I hope that
in a way that it's a conduit for people
who think that they don't like history
to realize actually they do and there
are these fascinating stories that that
they will absolutely love well the
so-called popular historians have also
stepped into a gap that has been left by
the decline of narrative history in the
academic departments and their various
theories about the cause of that but as
the academic historians dig more and
more deeply into very specialized areas
often with political or ideological
patents to
the field is really left wide open for
people who long tell stories tell
stories right and that's what I love to
do yeah there are microphones in the
middle of each aisle I believe and
you're welcome to come up and ask
Afghanistan anything you'd like to you
were first so you get the first yeah
well being a part of the time at least I
teach history and other things in high
school I appreciate your books cuz they
are colorful you know history to me is
very exciting and when you take colorful
figures or compelling historic figures
like you've you've written about I think
you've had a lot quite a bit now when
dealing with Churchill and the Boer War
of course one of the primary source is
going to be a lot of what Churchill
wrote but I always find that he
exaggerated stings and he likes to put
himself in the best light so how did you
deal with the challenge of dealing with
that well you know the nice thing is
that for most of the part at the time he
wasn't alone when he so the way he's
captured for those of you who don't know
he was very soon he went to the the Boer
War to cover it out to journalists he
was on very soon after he arrived he was
on an armoured train that was attacked
by the Boers and so his good friend al
Moore Halden had invited him along he
was actually in command of the Train and
invited him along and he was there and
many other men including the Boers who
were attacking them and so I have their
accounts of it as well and the same
thing when he was in the POWs can't the
other men so so they're almost always
and even when he was on the run he hid
in this in this coal mine shaft with
these white rats for three days
the men who helped them also wrote about
it and so and they really did Robert the
only thing that I found that that he got
wrong and he was very insistent about
this so he the man who organized the
attack on this train was a man named
Louie Bota and you may know he later
became the first prime minister of South
Africa and he was a very young
charismatic exciting general
and they became friends later in life
and Churchill always insisted that it
was bo2 personally who had captured him
and and then later
Churchill's son started researching he
was writing biography of his father and
he said you know I've done the research
and I don't think it could have been
botos just it's impossible that it was
bo2 who personally captured you and
Churchill said it was and but it wasn't
but a boat it was their boat to organize
a boat to saw everything and talked
about it but that's the the main thing
that I think is just not true thank you
thank you this is more of a general
historical question in terms of your
writing and hearing about how you decide
what you're going to use in your
research and what you don't use when you
do your research how do how do
historical writers avoid revising
history to their own liking I'm sorry
they avoid how do you avoid revising
history to your own personal opinions
about things well I do a lot of research
you know and I I don't come at it so
with an opinion I really don't so for
instance my I wrote a book about James
Garfield and I honestly did come to
admire him but I didn't even set out
wanting to write about James Garfield I
was wanting to write about Alexander
Graham Bell and I found out that he
invented something called an induction
balance to try to find the bullet in
Garfield and my five huh I wonder what
James Garfield was like you know he was
killed so early into his first term and
he's largely been forgotten and so I
started researching him and he was
extraordinary is absolutely brilliant he
was kind he was instrumental in bringing
about black suffrage he was just a
decent modest human being
and I was impressed with him but I
didn't start out thinking I want to make
people think that he was this
extraordinary man I I took him as I
found him and and that's what I tried to
do with with all my books I should I
might interject that I know the well
he's complaining about just not to pick
on one person but Arthur Schlesinger jr.
in his first first in his multi-volume
in complete history at the Roosevelt
administration Franklin Roosevelt and
then in his various writings on Jack
Kennedy was writing from a very distinct
ideological point of view and was and
may may have been bending history to
suit to suit his ideology sure I'm sure
and so it does happen so my question is
actually about destiny of the Republic I
I loved it and I came away after reading
it thinking that we missed out on a
potentially great president so I just
wanted to hear your thoughts on if
Garfield had not been assassinated what
type of president do you think he would
have been and would he have been
different than maybe some of those other
string of the 19th century presidents I
agree I believe that he would have been
one of our one of our great presidents
and I think that he was an inspiration
really to the country because he had
come from such poverty and and he seemed
to bring the country together in a way
that was a sharp contrast from what
happened after after Lincoln's
assassination we're really divided the
country even more and it's because so
many people admired him and so many
people had put so much hope into him and
as I said he was a very progressive
thinker for that time he and and and if
you can imagine it didn't even want to
be President was forced shoved into this
into this situation and so I think that
because of that he was uniquely powerful
because he wasn't beholding to anyone
you know he
made any promises he hadn't made any
sacrifices because it's not something he
you know he hungered for and it's he
used to called the presidential fever
and he saw it all around him because he
had been in Congress from almost
eighteen years so I do think that would
have made him a uniquely powerful
president had he lived and I do think it
was quite a loss to the country
I told Candace when we talked before but
I came to the end of Destiny of the
public with a tremendous sense of loss
that that this man never had his
opportunity to be the president he could
have been you made a brief reference to
the British policy of concentration
camps in the Boer War which was really
one of the most shameful episodes in the
British Empire's history particularly
its impact on women and children and
other non-combatants dead
Churchill ever acknowledged that or did
that affect him in any way well it what
affected him and I don't know it was his
own imprisonment and it affected him
deeply and he never forgot it and even
though it was completely on the other
end of the spectrum from the
concentration camps and just for those
of you who don't know so the the British
had gotten into the war thinking it's
going to last a couple of months and
will it start an October would be out by
Christmas and it ended up lasting almost
three years and so by the end they were
desperate to get out and so they they
did some pretty horrible things they
resorted to scorched earth policy and
they set up these concentration camps
for as you say the the women and
children who were supporting these men
who were out fighting in the field the
Boers and said that they wouldn't have
any support and it was disastrous it was
well and native Africans were also
forced into concentration camps and even
more of them died than the Boers
Churchill on the other hand his
imprisonment the Boers were eager to
show the British that they
civilized to the British had always sort
of dismissed them as sort of being
backward and rough and so they allowed
just like incredible leniency but
Churchill couldn't stand the idea of
being captured in fact he said he hated
that period in his life more than he had
ever hated any other period in his whole
life and he was desperate to get out and
he remembered that so so later on when
he gets into public life and he becomes
Home Secretary it was one of his
missions to show compassion to two
prisoners and you know he made sure that
they had access to books they had access
to the outdoors that they could exercise
because he said you know whether or not
they are guilty of some horrendous crime
they are still human beings first off
I'd like to say your first two books
were wonderful some of the best I've
ever read thank you
my question is that early on in the book
there's a sort of about passing
reference to Teddy Roosevelt I think the
other journalist Atkins I believe had
met him in Cuba and I just couldn't
believe how close those two seemed so
could you contrast Teddy Roosevelt and
Winston Churchill yeah I threw out the
process I kept thinking how much they
reminded me of each other how many
similarities they were these young
incredibly ambitious men very arrogant
drive everybody around them crazy
I'm incredibly well-read very very
talented writer so they had so much in
common and I think that's why they
really didn't like each other too too
similar and and they and they did meet
and yeah it definitely wasn't a love
affair
thank you since Churchill went to South
Africa as a journalist he had certain
kind of preconceived notions about the
British Empire and as he experienced the
Boer War how did his view change about
the British Empire did he really realize
did you see evidence that he realized
that the Sun was actually setting on the
British Empire at this time and my
second question is if he did did that
contribute to some of the most amazing
things he did in life like the Battle of
London when Hitler was trying to take
over England and he was so stalwart that
idea of I don't ever want to be
dominated again
did you see evidence of him changing his
thinking towards what the British Empire
was and how he wanted it to fit into the
world well I think we all know that
Winston Churchill was far from a perfect
man and one of the things about him is
that he was an unabashed
and imperialist he was very proud of the
British Empire and its standing in the
world and felt that it was part of his
mission to keep it keep it intact and I
I don't think the the Boer War changed
that at all I mean I think that another
thing and on the opposite side that I
will say about Winston Churchill is
something that I admire is that although
no one fought harder than he did during
war
no one was quicker to reach out the hand
of friendship afterward and he was
incredibly magnanimous and trying to
help someone who had so lately been his
enemy and that was true absolutely
during the Boer War and it got him in
trouble with his countrymen and it was a
you know true later in his life you can
see that and that was a sort of a
constant throughout his life but he was
at that time and
and for many many years absolutely an
imperialist hi um I just want to say
that I felt that destiny or the Republic
was an extraordinary book and how much I
enjoyed reading it as I was reading it I
totally marveled at the conversations
that the characters had with each other
and you know as if you had a tape
recorder in their room and I was
wondering how he what you drew upon to
get such verisimilitude in terms of what
these people were actually saying to
each other or how you did that so well
that's interesting my father said the
same thing after you read this book he
is like the dialogue that you have he's
like you know a novel or something and
it's very very important to me that
everybody knows that this is all
absolutely factual and I get that
dialogue from letters from the accounts
that they wrote themselves you know and
so I was talking to Churchill and he
said this and I said that and that's
where all that comes from and it's very
unfortunate I think that there's sort of
a trend sometimes the narrative
nonfiction that in the notes section you
just get a paragraph about each chapter
saying it kind of in general this is
these were my sources but in my books
you can look it up I put I use notes and
and so you can say what how does she
know that he said that well turned to
the notes and you can find out and you
can look it up yourself and so that's
something that's really really important
to me and just going back to primary
source material I mean it takes me a
long time before I will commit to a
subject even if I think it's a fantastic
story and there have been stories that
broke my heart because I really really
wanted to tell them but I finally had to
give them up because I just didn't have
enough primary source material to work
with to have that dialogue to have those
details that you hope will bring a story
alive and and so unless I do I just
won't commit to it and
and I had a wealth of information to
work with for this one sir thank you
hello you may have touched on this
earlier concerning the river of doubt as
I was reading it I was just amazed that
why Theodore Roosevelt was doing this
weight assigned why do you believe what
was his motivation for doing it I mean
it was just I just I don't want to give
you my own opinion well so for those of
you who don't know the story so that
theater bozo he lost the election of
1912 and and then he goes to the South
America and he goes down this incredibly
incredibly dangerous Rapids choked river
that no one knows where it leads that's
why the man who found the headwater is
called the Rio de vida the river of
doubt and because no one knew where it
was going to take them and what was
around each Bend and and the reason he
did it was because he was Theodore
Roosevelt and Winston Churchill would
have done it too so he's so you know he
had one and one and one throughout his
life and then he loses and he loses this
huge contest and he's a pariah for the
first time in his life he sees put
Woodrow Wilson a Democrat in the White
House cuz he split the Republican vote
and and and he you know had this
depression that had sort of haunted him
through his life and he was devastated
and so he gets this invitation to go on
a speaking tour in South America he's
this incredible naturalist has written
many books about specially birds and so
he's going to take another collecting
trip he gets there and and nobody's been
preparing he let this this friend of his
who was a priest who hired an arctic
explorer to plan this trip in the Amazon
and so they're not even prepared for
just a collecting trip and he gets there
in the foreign minister says you could
do that or you could map an unmapped
River and Theodore Roosevelt is going to
say
no to that no and so he throws him into
himself and the people with him into
this outrageously dangerous trip just
climbed it one more thank you a lucky
person can you talk a little bit about
how you reconstructed the events after
President Garfield was shot particularly
the medical care he received and find it
so remarkable that if the doctors had
left him alone he might very well lived
right yeah he would have so again for
those of you don't know today so
Garfield was shot actually in a train
station that was on the mall it's where
the National Gallery now sets and to my
outrage there is no plaque no notice at
all that an American president was shot
here but the bullet that hit him that
went in the right side of his back it
didn't hit any vital organs didn't hit
his spinal cord his his injuries were
far less severe than Reagan's when when
Reagan was shot and and his but he had
12 different doctors especially this
beautifully named doctor dr. Willard
bliss whose first name was doctor who
repeatedly inserted on sterilized
fingers and instruments in his back
probing for this bullet even though
Joseph Lister of listerine had
discovered antisepsis 16 years earlier
and come here and spoke to American
doctors and so it is sickening to watch
this you know through the lens of a
hundred and thirty-five years happening
to this to this extraordinary man and
and so I went a lot of so I did a ton of
research obviously at the Library of
Congress because even though Garfield
was president for a short time he had
been Congress for almost 18 years and
his papers and a lot of the people
surrounding it were in there but also I
went to the National Museum of Health
and medicine and they actually have the
autopsy report
there but more than that they have I
held in my gloved hand a section of
Churchill's of sorry Garfield's spine
with this red plastic pin going through
where the where the bullet had gone
through and it's a stunning and they
also have strangely there they have what
I called the assassins drawer because
they have these they have the remains of
Charles Bhutto who assassinated Garfield
and then they also have their manes of
John Wilkes Booth kind of in the same
drawer they have there's a femur there's
an ankle bone it's just bizarre they
also have a jar with chunks of guiteau's
brain and they he he was insane he was
he was mentally ill and after he was
executed they exhumed his body and they
wanted to study it for science to see
especially his brain to see if you could
see physical signs of insanity and so
they cut up his brain and they sent it
to experts around the country and they
sent it back and said well he probably
had syphilis but that's all we can tell
and they put it in this jar and they
still have it thank you Candice told me
before we started this program that she
is still looking around for her next
subject she also admitted that a book
for her is about a five-year project
Candice I am almost 77 years old and I
want to read your next book
[Applause]
and you're watching book TV on c-span 2
this is live coverage of the 16th annual
National Book Festival in Washington DC
the next author you'll hear speak in the
history and biography room will be Jon
Meacham talking about his biography of
President George HW Bush that's at about
an hour and 15 minutes or so
but right now here on our set in the
entrance of the convention center we are
joined by author and associate editor of
The Washington Post Bob Woodward whose
most recent book is this the last of the
president's men Bob Woodward who is the
last of the president's men Alexander
Butterfield who was one of Nixon's
deputies actually had the office
adjacent to the Oval Office for a couple
of years who was in on the deceits and
secrets and decided to disclose the
existence of the secret taping system
which provided the evidence that led to
Nixon's downfall and resignation did he
disclose it on purpose well this is one
of the stories in the book he
Butterfield's wife thinks he did that he
wanted to tell Butterfield kind of
denies that and then he acknowledges
that he was quite upset about the lies
and the extent to which he'd been drawn
into this web of corruption in the Nixon
White House and so people come out
differently what I'm able to chart with
the documents and the extensive
interviews with Butterfield and his
stories never told in detail is the
various steps if you will the Stations
of the Cross in making that decision
well Bob Woodward is our guest and of
course you know him from the Watergate
era and all the president's men and
seventeen other books that he has
written his most recent just came out
last year in 2015 we're going to put the
phone numbers up on the screen because
this is your chance to talk with Bob
Woodward 2:02 is he area code
if you live in the East and central time
zone 7 4 8 8200 you can dial in there
now if you live in the mountain in
Pacific time zones it's two zero two
seven four eight eight two zero one
there's a third way of getting a hold of
us this is not for phone calls this is
simply for text messages and if you do
send a text message please include your
first name and your city so we can
identify you that way but the text
message number is two zero two eight
three eight six two five one and we'll
get to your calls and text messages very
quickly as we go through Bob Woodward
it's been 40 plus years since Watergate
happened how did you find what did you
find with Alex defender butterfat I ran
into him at a conference and and said we
ought to talk we started talking I went
to his home and La Jolla California
because I realized the personal story
the struggle the the issue of moral
choice had never really been laid out
and when I visited Butterfield I asked
you have any documents and he said oh
well yeah a few 20 boxes thousands of
documents which I had never seen before
which had not been known to the world
and it's again a whole additional layer
of Nixon's isolation corruption
criminality and so it's a it's a very
close-up portrait it's as if the cameras
right in Butterfield's face peering into
his soul to a certain extent as he
describes exactly what happened to him
how was he able to keep 20 boxes of
Watergate or Nixon related material when
he left the White House kind of resigned
needed to get out in 1973 before
everything was unraveling on the
Watergate story he just pulled his car
and his wife and they loaded the 20
boxes
right there from the executive office
building next to the White House again
it's kind of the lesson is you don't
know what you can get away with unless
you try what did you find in those 20
boxes again he Butterfield told me
stories I wasn't sure were precisely
accurate and then there would be a
document describing it one of the ones
that surprised me shocked me in fact was
a memo top-secret memo from early 1972
that Kissinger had sent to Nixon about
it's kind of a routine update on the
Vietnam War and Nixon wrote in his
handwriting
the Kissinger said you know when the
bombing in Southeast Asia Vietnam has
gone on for 10 years we've achieved
zilch it's been a failure and of course
he was touting that the bombing was very
successful and it turns out after he's
made this declaration and the bombing
studies since have shown he was right it
was achieving nothing except kind of
energizing the North Vietnamese and so
what did Nixon do this is the year of
reelection 1972 the polling showed
starkly that bombing was popular it
showed he was tough so instead of
stopping the bombing killing people he
intensified the bombing in that year
1972 ordered the dropping of 1.1 million
tons of bombs how did Alexander
Butterfield get to the White House yeah
it was an accident he knew Haldeman who
was Nixon's top aide chief of staff from
UCLA Butterfield was an Air Force
colonel
he asked to interview Haldeman and and
Haldeman realized here's somebody
out of airforce central casting somebody
would be perfect to bring in as his
deputy
he did that with Nixon's approval but
Nixon didn't meet Butterfield until the
first weeks of the presidency in on
their meeting the scene is described it
shows how Nixon literally could not talk
all he did was mumble 202 is area code 7
for 8 8200 for those of you in the east
and central time zone 7 4 8 8 2 0 1 for
those of you in the mountain and Pacific
time zones and our text number for text
messages two oh two eight three eight
six two five one is mr. Butterfield
still alive he is he's 90 years old
lives in California's on a couple of
nonprofit boards and is you know he was
just sitting there and this again is one
of the journalistic lessons in all of
this you've got to show up you've got to
ask people and who would have ever
thought there would be another dimension
to Nixon the Nixon presidency and there
it was just sitting do you think a lot
of the documents the attitudes in the
Nixon White House were unique compared
to some other White House's I do and in
historical record shows that there was a
kind of anger there was a sense that
Nixon head of the presidency oh it's his
he's been elected it's personal it's not
about the people it's about him and so
he in many ways use the presidency as an
instrument of personal revenge let's get
the IRS the FBI the CIA on enemies or
perceived enemies other presidents have
been vengeful there's no question about
it but it was a way of life and it was a
policy
in the Nixon White House President Nixon
died in 1994 did you ever have a private
conversation with him
no Carl Bernstein and I tried a number
of times and he declined understandably
they did die in 94 and he spent and so
that was 20 years after he resigned
which was in 1974 and Nixon spent that
20 years giving interviews to David
Frost writing books his memoirs into a
very large extent he spent that time
declaring a war against history to kind
of say well what I really meant
Watergate was just a blip it was not as
serious as people made it out to be
and of course Nixon resigned not because
of the Democrats or the media he
resigned because of the Republican Party
which saw this evidence in the final
tapes all of the testimony and
exemplified by Barry Goldwater the
conservative from Arizona who took the
position too many crimes too many lies
at what point Bob Woodward in 1972-73
did you know your life was going to
change and revolve around this it was
incremental in October 1972 before Nixon
was reelected Carl Bernstein and I had
written lots of these stories people
didn't believe it it was inconceivable
and Carl to his credit realized that it
was likely Nixon was going to be
impeached because there was so much here
there was so much corruption so much
sabotage and espionage directed at the
Democratic presidential candidates let's
begin with a call from Ray and Ottawa
Illinois ray you're on with author Bob
Woodward go ahead ray
mr. Woodward hi Big Ben I'm a big fan of
your writing and I really appreciate the
work you've done covering Washington I
want to make this as concise as I
possibly can would you ever consider
writing a presidential history of mr.
Obama and what what is your opinion and
your coverage of Washington has tried
that Republican Vesely Lee hate the name
so deeply that they will never work with
him and they tried to sabotage his
presidency all right we got the point
ray thank you okay thank you I've
written two books on Obama Obama's Wars
about the Afghan war policy making and
then the second one the price of
politics about the budget negotiations
with the Republicans at this point Obama
gets I think a mix has a mixed record
achieved a good number of things a lot
of people a lot of Democrats agree with
this he did not develop the personal
relations with people in Congress and
could have done a lot more on the money
issues I think on the foreign policy
issues he did some things but I remember
talking to one of our the prime minister
of one of the countries our closest
allies who said he really liked Obama
thought Obama was smart but no one was
afraid of him and there's a record there
and when I interviewed President Obama
he made it very clear he does not like
war sometimes it's necessary but the
core of Obama is war is a manifestation
of human folly I think he's right but in
the world of Putin's you need to be
tough and he probably was not tough
enough and if you go to Bob Woodward
dot-com you can see the listing of all
of mr. Woodward's books Cathy and Linda
Washington Tech's into you can you
compare the illegal act of Nixon with
what Hillary Clinton secrecy and
illusion email and foundation emails the
record on the tapes and the record in
all the Nixon investigations was the
level of corruption and criminality
unequaled there are lots of questions
about Hillary Clinton's emails and
secrecy and other activity as the FBI
director said recently they're not
recommending a prosecution of her
there's no evidence of criminality he
said a lot of people agree with that a
lot of people disagree with it we now
have the situation where Secretary
Clinton is said she turned over all the
work-related